- Santa, I can definitely
tell you're not a cheap guy
at the mall saying, "Sit on my lap.
What do you want for Christmas?"
This beard sticks on.
- Yeah.
("Santas Anthem")
- I'm Jewish.
- We celebrate Hanukkah.
- I like lighting the candles,
like those people did in the desert.
- I like to spin the dreidel.
- I like potatoes latkes a lot.
- Hanukkah's about being with your family,
but I'm a little dirty, I
like the presents myself.
- Santa doesn't come to my
house because I'm Jewish.
And also, I don't believe in Santa Claus.
- On Christmas Eve, he
goes into your house
and gives you presents
through the chimney.
- And Santa has reindeers.
- He has a list of nice and naughty.
- And the thing I don't
believe is he lives forever.
Now that's what kind of
puts me on the fence there.
("Santas Anthem")
- I never met Santa before.
Yeah.
- Ho, ho ho!
(Santa laughing)
Oh my goodness. It's me Santa Claus.
I'm so glad to see you.
- Is his beard real?
- Can I sit there? Here,
let me help you out.
(Santa laughing)
- Umm.
- Do you hang out with Hairy Hanukkah?
- I love back scratchers, by the way.
(Santa laughing)
- So the dreidel came
as you spin the dreidel
with your friend, probably
you need two people.
- But then I turn smaller when
I go down in the chimneys.
And then pop back out into normal size.
- No. I'm sure.
(Santa laughing)
- You probably land on
something like a Hebrew leather,
and whatever it says, you do.
- I have to go swoosh,
poop. And here I am again.
(Santa laughing)
- It's some strange stories for sure.
- No.
- It's not about presents. You
need to be you and live life.
If it means no presents
and being with your family,
sometimes you gonna live with it.
- And I feel exactly the same way.
- Santa, I wanna give you a cookie.
- Oh well, thank you,
sweetie. I appreciate that.
("Santas Anthem")
You wanna take a little
bite off the other end?
- No.
(Santa laughing)
("Santas Anthem")
- #imetSanta
(Santa laughing)
- Santa, I'm Jewish but I love you.
- Thank you, sweetie. I love you, too.